[Applaudissements]
encore bonne mine terrorisme et intérêts
l'inquiétant change réellement
les contributions important il est né
avec une malformation cardiaque je donne
quelqu'un pour l'aider à vivre d'autre
chose je cherche quelqu'un ne cherche
pas j'ai trouvé
pas du tout faits pour ça coucou
franchement je trouve que ça vachement
leurs enfants par un handicapé moi je
trouve que tu as l'air bien crever pour
un mec en pleine forme
me rendais pas compte et tous les
avantages que vous avez vous les
handicapés que j'ai envie de pisser way
fais pas le con je frapperai compte pas
c'est bien
super 15 heures où je ne vois cette
heure mois du matin
c'est quoi votre expérience avec les
enfants
j'en étais un plus je le suis toujours
ça fait 25 ans d'expérience
mais on m'a dit je vais écrire tout ce
que je voulais ans comme à noël soit
jamais jusqu'à surréaliste pas de bon
pas de gâteau à cause de son diabète
parce qu'en plus il fait du oui pas de
sport tout effort physique et en quoi
tout le reste
à jamais embrassé une fille à ton âge
il était temps j'arrive dans ta vie mon
patin
c'est quoi le programme aujourd'hui
excursions champêtre et un sms avec
photos toutes les campings
il va jamais croire et tu me prends pour
qui
et initiation à la botanique en forêt
c'est pas moi qui le mardi 15 juin
médecins
dis moi aussi lui c'est peut-être pour
ça qui te fait confiance alors
[Applaudissements]
j'adorerais avoir une vie normale
[Musique]